Throughout 2018, there were plenty of major
blockbusters and indie films alike that were
big hits with audiences despite being panned
by critics.
Don't let the negative reviews discourage
you from checking them out.
Here are a few films that deserve a second
look, contrary to the critical consensus.
The character Venom first appeared on the
big screen in 2007's Spider-Man 3, but 2018's
Venom gives viewers a new origin story for
the famous anti-hero.
When Eddie Brock, played by Tom Hardy, tries
to investigate the Life Foundation for running
dangerous human trials, he ends up accidentally
bonding with an alien slime and developing
strange powers.
Even though Venom has been criticized for
everything from its dialogue to its plot to
its cinematography, it's a fun, campy film
that stands on its own.
The technical details might be clunky, and
the visuals might seem cliche, but it's the
kind of train wreck that you won't feel guilty
about sticking around to watch.
"I have proof!"
The Nun is the fifth installment in The Conjuring
franchise, and turned out to be the highest-grossing
entry since the original.
Although fans of the series flocked to theaters
to see it, critics didn't exactly hold it
in high esteem.
The Nun was dismissed by some critics as a
series of jump scares and other horror tropes.
Still, there's a lot to like in the film,
notably Taissa Farmiga, and fans will find
that it's a welcome addition to the franchise
with familiar themes on the struggle between
good and evil.
"We need to pray, now.
And whatever happens, whatever you may see
or hear, keep your eyes forward and don't
stop praying."
The Spy Who Dumped Me is a refreshing action
flick with a heavy dose of female empowerment.
After Audrey is unceremoniously dumped by
her boyfriend via text message, she discovers
that he's secretly a CIA agent… and now,
he's gone missing.
It's up to Audrey and her best friend Morgan
to figure out what's happened to him and come
to the rescue.
Most of the criticism of The Spy Who Dumped
Me focused on the film's refusal to pin itself
to one single genre.
Still, there's nothing wrong with a little
creative genre blending, and ultimately it
all comes together for a solidly entertaining
film.
"This is how people get shoved into the back
of sketchy vans, right?"
"That actually makes this awkward."
"Get in the van."
Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes of Grindelwald
brings Eddie Redmayne back to the big screen
as Newt Scamander.
Unfortunately, this new installment in the
Fantastic Beasts franchise struggled as far
as the critics were concerned.
In the film, Newt joins forces with Albus
Dumbledore as they race to stop the infamous
dark wizard Grindelwald from establishing
a worldwide wizard supremacy.
The Crimes of Grindelwald has been criticized
for packing in too many plot twists and tiny
details for the audience to keep track of,
and putting the actual exciting magic on the
back burner.
Still, there's something to be said for a
film that demands your close attention throughout
if you want to fully grasp the storyline.
In Tully, Charlize Theron plays Marlo, a stressed,
sleep-deprived mother of two with another
baby on the way.
When her brother offers to pay for a night
nanny to lessen her load, she eventually accepts.
The new nanny's name is Tully, and she brings
a new energy to Marlo's life.
While some critics felt that Theron's performance
was the only winning note in this film, Tully's
strength lies in the fact that it shows a
realistic side of modern motherhood that most
movies are hesitant to touch on.
Marlo might be exhausted and overworked, but
she refuses to lose her own identity in motherhood.
"Are you okay?"
"Oh.
Yeah.
That's milk.
I make milk."
Rampage stars Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson as
a primatologist who has to stop three giant
rampaging monsters: a gorilla, a wolf, and
a crocodile.
As far as sci-fi monster movies go, Rampage
really isn't half bad, taking the video game
premise into action movie territory.
What could be more fun than watching The Rock
fight giant monsters?
Although Vulture called the film "aggressively
dumb," director Brad Peyton clearly knew what
his target audience wanted: Rampage was nominated
for several Teen Choice Awards.
The Meg follows a group of scientists, one
of whom is played by the incomparable Jason
Statham, who unexpectedly run into a megalodon
shark in the depths of the Pacific Ocean.
The Meg isn't going for realism, but it's
got plenty of moments that will make you laugh,
and a few that will make you shudder.
The film might have been criticized as "neither
good enough nor bad enough" by Variety, but
that didn't stop plenty of eager viewers from
flooding the cinema to see it.
The Meg hits that sweet spot somewhere between
Jaws and Sharknado.
“Aw yeah, jellyfish."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.